hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website common to date we're in
game number three of the 2018 World
Chess Championships from London England
between the champion Magnus Carlsen who
today will have the black pieces in his
opponents Fabiano Caruana playing the
white pieces first two games were both
draws first game lasted seven hours
second game not nearly that long but
still a few hours before they decided to
pack it in before the rest day yesterday
they did have a full day off just to
relax hang out with their team figure
out a strategy coming for the next two
days so Fabiano starts out with the
white pieces in game number three Pawnee
Ford much like we saw in at game number
one we see Magnus continuing with the
Sicilian defense pawn c5 Knight f3
knight c6 Bishop to b5 same line as
before this is how Fabiano wants to
attack pawn g6 Bishop takes pawn
recapture here on c6 and then pawn d3
followed by fianchetto to g7 reason
going through these fairly fast is
they're the exact same moves from game
number one feel free to go back and
watch that but this is where things get
different because in game number one we
saw pawn to h3 this is the main line of
what white lights to do here that's not
what Fabiano decides to play instead
castle on the kingside only took about
ten seconds for this move so you can
tell this is part of this preparation
Magnus Carlsen only took about a minute
and played Queen to c7 if you are
watching live listen to the commentary
you you knew that this position although
seems pretty common for white to castle
on the King side and right here this
specific place is not really when you
see it you're normally gonna see it
after pawn to h3 and then only later on
would you castle so Magnus Carlsen may
have been caught off guard a little bit
he's send to look around after he saw
castle on the King side but he played
Queen to c7 fairly quickly and from here
we continue rook to e1 Pawnee 5 and then
pawn to a 3 in game number one we saw
more of the
Bishop to e3 attack in the pond pond
down here to b6 and then the knight gets
involved into the game
Fabiana going for a different approach
maybe later wants to bring his Bishop to
g5 instead of just here at e3 but first
starts with pawn to a3 kind of inviting
if his opponent wants to play that
pawned to b6
I'm sure let's go ahead and push up with
pawn to b4 here
I think Fabiana would be okay with that
no reason for madness Carlsen to push
right here since his pawn on c5 is not
under attack
instead he decides good and bring his
knight out here to f6 now Fabiano
decides to push with pawn to b4 he has a
nice little attack defended by the pawn
on a3 probably part of hit you know in
the back of his mind thinking if Magnus
Carlsen did castle on the Queen side of
the board after he played pawned aged 6
so just wants to make sure that if
Magnus Carlsen is trying any of those
shenanigans in game number 3 that he
starts his push early and often in the
game Magnus Carlsen immediately just
decides to castle on the King side and
then from here we see Knight - D - if
you kind of look at this this pawn looks
just ready for the taking
I think for all intents and purposes you
can just take this right away and for
most people you really can't just it's a
free pawn pawn takes here on c5 maybe
Bishop to e6 getting it involved here
Bishop to e3 these double pawns here on
the C file so later in the game this is
gonna be more difficult for white to
hold on to the edge that he has black
definitely has this semi open file he
can bring his rooks over to if he wants
to control the center of the board so in
that respect Magnus Carlsen does have
some compensation for giving up that
pond but mere mortals would have a hard
time not just being up a full point from
this position you know you could start
to pusher your knight here you're just
gonna come back maybe pawn to h3 instead
so you don't have to worry about this
but now your bishops in a fine spot here
work over here to d8 to control that let
up here g5 attacking the bishop bishop
back to C 893 you can tell
even if we're looking at solid moves
from black it's not clear how he's gonna
get this material any time soon so in
the game I feel like we would have just
seen the pond take on c5 but instead
Knight take or Knight to d2 followed by
Bishop down here to g4 pawn age 3 says
yeah you're gonna want to kick that back
unless you want to exchange and that's
exactly what we see Bishop takes here
Knight takes so magnus carlsen no longer
has the bishop pair on board and we see
the pond take on b4 pawn captures here
and then pawn down here to a5 then we
start to see some exchange on board pawn
takes now the rook takes and so you can
start to see things are opening up on
the Queen side of the boards can be very
difficult for both sides to hold on to
so much material this because it's so
easy for both sides to just start
exchanging material now Bishop to d2
attacking the rook there on a5 where it
comes back to aid could have just
exchanged if you wanted to but decides
to bring it back here Queen to b1 he has
the night here on f3 attacking the pawn
on e5 this pawn on e5 is only defended
by the Queen on c7 so wants to get the
Queen more involved in the game also
attacking this pawn on b7 which is also
only defended by the Queen on c7 so as
he's just trying to get a better
position trying to see what material he
can't attack figures that the Queen here
on b1 is a better Square Knight to d7
this does get in a better position to
defend this night or this pawn here on
e5 and then we see Queen to b4 really
just doing the same thing as before but
more active also allows this rook here
on e 1 to protect this rook on a1 while
still attacking the same squares that he
was before rook to e8 another defender
on the pawn on e5 Bishop to c3 attacking
that pawn pawn down here to b5 rook
takes rook takes here we're cover here
to a-1 and then we see in exchange both
sides saying yeah we're just gonna
exchange as much material as we can and
this starts to look like a very drawn
game both sides do have the most
powerful piece the Queen but they do
have two other minor piece
says they do have both the rooks off the
game it's not clear how either side is
going to continue and come up with a
victory here but Queen to a7 attacking
the bishop bishop comes back here to c3
Queen down to a2 attacking the pawn here
on c2 White has a couple options if he
wants to get frisky play something like
Queen to e7 say yeah you can take my
pawn here I'm gonna gobble up your
knight you can start to gobble up my
material yeah I put you in check bring
your Bishop up here to f8 I can get my
knight involved yes you're going to
check me get some material here on f2
that's one option the other option is to
say you know what not gonna be doing too
much here I don't see a great line to
continue and play Queen down to be to
exchange material right here so from
here we're only 24 moves in in my
opinion if the players could agree to a
draw they would have as you know the
rules of the tournament you cannot draw
before 30 move so they continue on f6
then King to f1 getting the Kings above
them to the game King to f7 King here e
to Knight down here to c5 Bishop to c3
Knight to e6 just maneuvering the pieces
all over the place
pawn up here to g3 so this is stopping
the knight coming down here to f4 you
always want to see where your opponent's
can move just stop those pieces from
getting to those critical squares
especially nice little outpost also
checking the opponent's things could
have gone poorly for Fabiano if he
doesn't block off those squares Bishop
here to f8 wants to get involved you can
see over here on g7 hasn't moved since
it fee and kiddo too early on wants to
get that piece involved into the game so
Bishop here to f8 with the thought of
getting it very involved very quickly
Knight down here to d2 Knight to g5
attacking the pawn pawn just gonna push
up here to h4 comes back to e6 Knight to
b3 pawn down to h5 Bishop down d2 and
then Bishop to d6 you can see both sides
not really making much headway in the
game but they are moving around see if
they can just find a small advantage
and take control white continues with
ponzu c3 and then c5 Bishop here III
King II 7 King down here to d1 an
interesting but you could just see how
Fabiano's maneuvering is king over to
the Queen side that board just doesn't
want to put it on dark squares it's the
same amount of moves to come over here
but he recognizes his opponent does have
a dark squared Bishop so don't even have
to think about it put it all on light
squares pawn to f5 King back here to d1
and then the pawn takes pawn takes here
pawn down to c4 forcing the Knights and
move we see the knight to a c5 Bishop
takes and then Bishop recaptures at this
point they have gone past 40 moves they
do get 50 additional minutes added on so
what do both players do they get up and
they leave to take a break and this
happens quite a few times when they know
they are in a theoretical drawing
position it's gonna be very difficult
for either side to come out of with this
a victory but they've just been playing
for hours now and they're just tired and
so they just get up and they just left
they eventually did come back and from
here they didn't play too many moves
past this King to e2 c6 and knights to
f1 pawn down to before we do see an
exchange on the board and then it was
interesting how Fabiana decided to take
instead of he could've taken pawn to f5
would have still been a draw but instead
decided to play Knight takes on c4
forcing the King to take here after pawn
takes on f5 49 moves we do have a drawn
game black if he wants to stop this pond
from pushing he's going to have to focus
his Bishop and his King on that he's not
able to stop the King coming and taking
material here on h5 if he doesn't want
to protect this he's gonna have to just
let this pawn push up the board so this
is going to be a drawn game no way to
really continue past this so game number
3 is in the books Magnus Carlsen I feel
like has to be feeling good because
he's only had white once had black two
times and we have three draws so far so
as most of the big tournaments we follow
its drawls early on that's just to be
expected or at least is what I expected
I am expecting Magnus Carlsen though to
come outs in the next game with
something special at least that is my
hope so but thank you guys so much for
watching the commentary for game number
three and I'll see you tomorrow for game
number four